[Musique]
on
m
monde
sujet éducatif est toujours un sujet
très sensible
d'abord parce qu on y attend beaucoup on
a beaucoup d'espérance par rapport à
cette question éducative est forcément
souvent des moments où il ya des
tensions des désaccords qui apparaissent
on le voit actuellement avec ce
ras-le-bol que qu'expriment les
enseignants par rapport à cette crise
sanitaire qui dure c'est aussi ça les la
grâce et de pouvoir répondre à un
certain nombre de problématiques qui se
posent
l'idée de cette agora c'est un lieu de
discussions des changes le débat sur
l'éducation à travers deux tables rondes
qui auront lieu successivement la
première sur les attentes par rapport à
l'éducation que souhaitons-nous de la
part de des écoles l'apprentissage de la
citoyenneté l'acquisition des savoirs
une meilleure égalité des chances et
puis la deuxième table ronde ça sera sur
la question de la réforme comment
peut-on réformer dans quelle direction
réformer l'éducation nationale comment
réorienter davantage sur des politiques
puis territoriales comment donner plus
d'autonomie aux établissements ou aux
acteurs locaux qu'il relève de
l'éducation nationale ou qu'ils relèvent
des collectivités sur cette
problématique et éducatifs ou re
éclairer les intervenants de ces deux
tables rondes nous avons effectué une
consultation des élus locaux qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent de l'éducation quelles
sont les difficultés qu'ils ont
éventuellement avec les écoles et puis
aussi un sondage auprès des parents et
auprès des enseignants et ainsi nous
aurons cette vision croisée des
principaux acteurs parents enseignants
élus locaux autour de l'éducation
égard à de nombreux intervenants erik
orsenna viendra être inséré un propos
préalable et puis après dans les tables
rondes nous aurons des spécialistes de
l'éducation des jeunes comme pierre
mathiot qui est qui a eu un rôle très
important sur la réforme du bac soit
diana et puis bien sûr des sénateurs
aussi qui interviendront qui suivent ces
questions avec attention depuis de
nombreuses années et bien sûr la table
ronde sera animée par gérard larcher
lui-même et moi même